[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
In today's video, we're going to take
a look at a few different methods
for how to fill bubbles with fuel
so you can light them on fire.
[Music]
In the past, we've shown you
a fun way to make bubbles
that you can hold down your hand,
and light on fire.
This is just a little bit of
bubble soap diluted with some water,
and a can of butane that
I'm just turning upside down,
and pressing onto
the bottom of the bowl.
That releases the butane,
it forms bubbles in the soap,
you can then scoop them up onto your hands,
and light them on fire.
It's a cool trick that
when you do it correctly,
is not all that dangerous.
Although of course, you still need
to be very sure that you're being careful.
But it's not quite what you might
imagine if you think of fire bubbles.
It is bubbles and
they can be lit on fire,
but we wanted to see if we could
do something a little bit different.
I was hoping that I could take an
actual bubble machine and modify it,
so that instead of just
blowing normal bubbles,
it blew bubbles full of a fuel,
so you could then light
the bubbles on fire.
I'm going to walk you through
the process I went through
as I explored whether or not
this was a viable project.
On the back of the bubble machine,
there's a small fan that
blows air through the machine
until it comes out the front.
A little circle of bubble wands
dips down into some soap,
rotates around and ends up
right in front of the fan.
That's where the bubbles
are all blown out.
So, my thought was that
if we could isolate the air intake,
and flood that with fuel,
it would just start blowing
fuel-filled bubbles out of the front.
Like with the bath of bubbles,
the plan was to use butane as a fuel.
A butane canister is cheap,
and we know that it doesn't just
destroy bubbles on contact with them.
There's probably several types
of fuel that are like that,
but we already know the butane works,
so that's the one I wanted to try.
So, how to direct the butane
from our little canister
onto the back of our bubble machine?
Well, what I came up with
was uh-- it was gloves.
I decided to try using
one of these rubber gloves
to see if I could attach
it onto the back of the fan,
and then to just use one of the fingers
as a fill point for the butane here.
So first step,
I'm just gonna use some tape,
and tape it down over
the whole air intake area.
[Music]
That's a glove just taped down
over the entire air intake
of this bubble dispenser,
and now, at this point,
if I hit this button,
it will actually suck some
of the air out of the glove.
Turn it on.
So, we know the air intakes is trying
to pull air from out of the glove.
That's what we want.
And now we need to attach the other end
of this glove to our butane container.
To do that, I'm just going
to stab or cut a very small hole
in the tip of one of the fingers,
and then I'm going to just
attach it around the nozzle.
Okay, we now have our nozzle
attached to the finger of the glove,
and the rest of the glove is
attached to the air intake of the fan.
See if we can...
See, I need to elevate this a little bit more.
All right, for my workshop,
I have a one of these just sitting there.
So, I'm going to use this.
The goal is to elevate
the bubble machine just enough
that I'm not kinking the connection
between the glove and the butane,
so it has a better chance
of filling correctly,
and not just getting trapped in there.
All right. Let's see what happens
if I grab the nozzle and press down on it.
[Music]
The glove seems to
inflate just a tiny tiny bit.
[Music]
You can see the finger certainly inflated.
But most of the glove doesn't,
and I'm pretty sure
that's actually just because
it's going all the
way through the glove,
through the fan,
and coming out in the
front of the bubble machine.
I have a-- I think an effective,
if somewhat dumb way to test that.
[Music]
Set this right-- Oh!
I think that's test
confirmed right there.
Enough butane had just settled
around here that it lit on fire.
But you can see that it becomes
flammable when I press down on here,
butane is traveling through.
So now the test is
to see what happens
if we turn on the machine while we're
pushing down on the butane nozzle.
Will we get bubbles flying out the front?
[Music]
Well, it was definitely flammable.
It was definitely taking
the fuel from the canister,
and blowing it out in the air.
But, you probably noticed,
it didn't actually
successfully make any bubbles.
See the bubble machine works
by just blowing a fan constantly,
and then the circular bubble wand
moves the different bubble wand
heads in front of the fan,
and that's where all
the bubbles come out.
But it doesn't only blow the air
when the wand is right
in front of the fan.
It's constantly blowing it out.
In between every one of
these bubble wands,
there's a lot of space.
If you try and light the bubbles
anywhere close to the machine,
you have a very real chance of
just hitting the stoichiometry,
where the fuel and the air
are mixed together
just right to go up
in a big old fire ball.
I think it would need to
be something a lot more precise
to be a fully automated machine,
something that dip the
bubble wand into bubbles,
puts in front of a nozzle,
a carefully shaped small volume nozzle
that's just going to blow the fuel
right into the bubble wand,
instead of just blanket
spraying fuel everywhere,
and hoping it catches some
bubbles as they move by.
So moving on from using
the pre-made bubble machine,
I still like the idea
of getting bubbles blown
through a bubble wand of some sort.
So, I wanted to try
a slightly different method
that did not use the bubble machine.
This bubble soap came
with this gnarly bubble wand
that does a pretty good job
of making some good size bubbles.
So, I thought maybe I could
modify a butane canister,
so we can just blow bubbles through here.
Those are good bubbles.
I like those bubbles.
So, I wanted a way
to direct butane sideways,
but by leaving the canister
straight up and down,
and that kind of made me
think of a can of spray paint.
Cans of spray paint are up and down,
the nozzles on the top,
paint comes out sideways.
How perfect!
That's just what we're looking for.
I do have an extra spray paint
nozzle from an empty spray paint.
This obviously was black spray paint,
and it fits fairly closely
on top of our butane canister.
It's kind of loose still, it spins.
But even with it spinning loose like that,
if I press down on the nozzle,
I can feel the butane
coming out the front.
I think there's also quite a
bit leaking out the bottom,
because as I said,
it's not a perfect seal.
So, what we want to do
is attach this nozzle
onto the butane canister a
little bit more permanently,
and to do that, we're going
to use some two-part epoxy.
We're going to mix up a little bit of this,
apply it on the little stem of the nozzle here,
and then put our cap on,
and really try and make sure
that we get a nice tight seal,
so there won't be any gaps
and no leaking fuel,
except out the front.
Take our epoxy and start applying it.
And of course,
we want to make sure
that it doesn't go all the way
up onto the top of the nozzle,
because that would block it up,
and we do not want to block it up.
We just want to stop it
from coming out the sides.
So we choose where it comes out.
Put that in.
I'm just going to twist it
back and forth to try and get
that epoxy to bond on
everywhere in a circle.
Right now, it's making
contact all the way around.
So now, I'm going to
flip it back right side up,
because I don't want to have any epoxy
accidentally running down the nozzle,
and just filling and blocking it all up.
So right now,
that should be in a spot
where it will be attached,
and form a seal all the way around,
but it should leave the nozzle open
to spraying once the epoxy is cured.
It's been a few minutes,
and the epoxy is cured.
So we have a nozzle on top
of our butane canister,
and I believe we have butane
only coming out the nozzle,
and not leaking out the bottom.
Let's give it the upside down test.
[Music]
Plenty of butane
coming out the front,
but I don't see anything
spraying out the gap here.
[Music]
I'd call that a success.
Let's see if we can use this
butane bottle to fill some bubbles.
[Music]
Those are bubbles.
Blown with the butane canister.
So one of the main questions
is whether or not we can get
enough butane into these bubbles
for them to actually be flammable.
It could be that the
Bernoulli effect is causing there
to be so much air inside the bubbles
that it no longer is
a flammable level of fuel.
Here's a little bit of the science
behind what might be happening.
The Bernoulli effect is something
that occurs with high velocity fluids.
When something like a stream of air
or gaseous fuel is moving really quickly,
it creates a low-pressure area.
Pressure always tries
to move from high to low,
and so, all of the air outside
of the low pressure zone
will try and rush in to fill
the low pressure zone,
which means that air would get pulled
through the bubble wand into the bubble,
along with the fuel.
Seems logical to me that
the best way to test
if there's enough butane is
to try and light them on fire.
Let's give it a shot.
Ideally, this isn't
a one-person activity,
but I'm going to try
and make it work anyway.
I have here a little party sparkler.
I'm going to light the party sparklers.
I'm going to blow some bubbles
using the butane canister,
set that down,
quickly try and grab the sparkler,
and see if I can ignite the bubbles
before they just pop on the ground.
[Music]
Wind to stop changing.
Come back!
Oh! That one actually burned.
[Music]
Some of those worked.
It might have been really hard to see
on camera because it's daylight,
and it's just a small little flame.
But those ignited.
The sparklers have been
lighting off some of the bubbles.
But they don't do as good of a job as
I think just using the torch might do,
so, I'm going to try
just lighting the torch,
and blowing some bubbles,
and trying to light it off with that.
It might work a little bit better.
[Music]
Yeah!
But I think I'm getting
the hang of what does work.
If I don't press down quite as much,
letting out the butane in a slower stream,
it doesn't pop the bubble as often,
plus the pressure difference between
inside the bubble and
outside the bubble is lower,
so we get less air and more butane,
which is more flammable.
This is working okay.
Actually, a little better
than I thought it would.
But it's really hard to see in the daylight.
I think we need to go to night.
Okay.
There we go. That's better.
We should now be able to see
if things are actually lighting on fire.
Let's give it another try.
[Music]
I saw a little flame.
I saw another one.
[Music]
That was great.
That was exciting.
All right,
since I only have two hands,
I got my friend Keith to fill in.
He's got an extra hand.
He's gonna hold the torch.
I'm gonna make the bubbles.
Hopefully, we won't
light each other on fire.
We'll see.
[Music]
>> Ah, it's like whack-a-mole.
Gotta get them all.
[Music]
>> Not so close.
Butane in your face.
[Music]
He's in his 30s, folks.
>> I'm an adult.
>> But I'm the one blowing
bubbles so you know...
Dancing with a sparkler.
Blowing bubbles.
We're both adults.
It didn't work out so well
to make a bubble machine
that had flammable bubbles,
but just blowing gas into the
bubble soap worked out quite nicely.
I really like that effect.
It's something that I think
I would like to revisit.
Maybe trying to make bigger bubbles with
more gaseous fireball flames in them.
Or maybe just using some cooler
footage of doing this same thing.
Both of those would be really neat.
What would you like to see us try?
Guys! That's not all.
There's still more for you to see.
That little box up at the top will
transport you directly to our last video,
and you should go check it out.
The box down at the bottom will
show you what YouTube thinks
you need to be watching next,
and this bomb here in the middle
will subscribe you to our channel,
so you never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you on the next one.
Talk to you then.
Taunted by bubbles.